honestly it's kind of surreal you guys
oh what
hello i am harsheth
blaze what is up everybody
hello
is my audio kinda low
hello hello hello welcome welcome to the
stream welcome
uh the andrew garfield video to my
knowledge is real
um
i've seen some people even
even
proving that it's real and i asked to
contact today i was like all right bro
andrew's denying it like hardcore i get
that he can't say yes
but for real i was like
is he in the movie
and he was like yeah he is and i was
like like 100 and he was like yes i was
like okay
okay
this is good enough for me
wait did my thumbnail
oh it did
okay
so that's that's what i have um
i talked to my contact
and he he knows a lot i don't know how
he does i mean i know like
i know he's an insider and i know he
knows people at studios and stuff i
don't know if you've seen
toby in the in it but i was like
literally like 100 are you sure toby and
andrew are in it and he said yeah
okay
i have i have faith
i have faith i just got done watching
the very first episode of star wars
visions and if you are an anime fan
you're going to really like it like even
if you don't
necessarily like star wars so much it's
essentially just an anime and instead of
samurai swords they're lightsabers like
it's so cool
i've only seen one episode and it was
like 14 minutes long they're short
episodes i think the longest episode
for visions is is 20 minutes long
so so they're pretty short they're
pretty short but uh i gotta say the
first one i watched it was very
different than i thought it was going to
be this first episode um
it was
it was very different the style of the
animation was very different but i kind
of liked it
um
i have not seen spider-man no home yet
no i have not watched it um
yeah the supposed leaker that faked
well okay so there was a guy that said
he
that he posted the video and he faked it
that he deep faked it
but he's now like private at his account
and he's like taking a lot of things
back so he was basically lying pretty
much
he is basically lying
hello yes i am good everybody i hope
everybody else is good i hope we're all
ready for some
killmonger iron man action today um i
think it's gonna be good i think it's
gonna be a good episode you know what i
don't even have disney plus pulled up
yet let's go ahead and do that
so i'm gonna try something different
tonight guys um
i'm going to try to break down what we
saw immediately after
we watch it i'm going to do it with
chris and um i'm going to we're going to
record it here live
and then i'll post it the next day we're
going to see how that works because i
think that could be a really cool way to
do it because it'll kind of have you all
be involved as well like in the chat and
everything like that so i think it would
be pretty cool and it'll help me do my
breakdowns as well i haven't been
consistent with these breakdowns because
other news has come out typically and
has taken precedence over that over what
if i i like what if
but considering how it doesn't
or like directly affect the mcu
that we know of right now like if
something else comes out i kind of gotta
i kind of gotta watch that all right i
kind of got to do a video on that you
know so
that just is what it is no big deal
sorry i lost my chat
here we go here we go got it back got it
back got it back
woof woof
a lot of people saying
malik what's up dude infinity shades
what's up how's everybody doing i see a
lot of the regulars in here
thomas martin and of course mr ana
anderson the excuse me
best mod in the world on the chat
boom boom boom here we go here we go
i i agree
that there does need to be a part two of
zombies like
i feel like that was i feel like it was
just very rushed at the end right like
that's how i feel i feel like it was
very rushed
and i think
we could deserve i think we do deserve
like a part two
so
what's up everybody welcome welcome
welcome who's my favorite avenger advait
the polanchi i think that's how you say
that
um thor
thor has always been my favorite avenger
um
wolverine has always been my favorite
marvel character
and i really can't wait till we get a
new one i love hugh jackman i think he
did an amazing job if he was 10 years
younger i think we'd have him back you
know um
i'd like to play
wolverine in the mcu
what is your least favorite film i'm
assuming you may you mean in in the mcu
um
and not just in general because that
that's a
that's a
that's a big one i don't think i could
even answer
that
so
but let's my least favorite mcu movie
i mean that's hard as well um
just even going through them i don't
even know
probably like i don't know because it's
a funny movie oh man probably
does the incredible hulk count because
i'll i'll throw that one in there i'll
say the incredible hulk uh with what
eric bana thinks his name
right
um yeah
i mean there are movies that
that i didn't quite enjoy you know as
much as other movies um
i don't know like black widow was okay i
didn't hate there's not like there's not
like
there's not like a movie that i hate
right like i think they're all good on
their own type of level somewhat right
um
i don't think there's any pure trash mcu
movie
you know but i mean like i
like the first ant-man movie i probably
ranked pretty low captain marvel i rank
pretty low the incredible hulk has to be
the lowest one for me to rank um
and not that it's bad
i it just doesn't matter
like it matters i guess right it's like
it's canons of the mcu but like it's you
know nobody really remembers it not a
lot of people remember that it's even
part of the mcu
um
i mean you know i rewatched the first
captain america movie the other day and
i never disliked the movie
but i forgot how good it was
because it was ranked low for me for a
while and then i i rewatched it a few
weeks ago for for the for the what if
episode for the first one and i was like
dang this is a freaking good movie like
i forgot how good the first captain
america movie was and of course winter
soldier is amazing and civil war is
amazing um
iron man 3 maybe
rank's pretty low um
yeah
is hawkeye a movie no
it's a series
disney plus um trailer for multiverse of
madness malik that's a good question um
hey kratos what's up always coming in
the chat what's up um
just kind of march doing math in my head
probably like
november december i i want to say
they're going to wait like around no way
home i want to say they're going to wait
till after no way home but
because they're so seemingly connected i
mean they are connected but the problem
is
you can't wait till after that's like
three months until
until the movie comes out
so
that would be really close like that
would be like really really close to
weight um
so i want to say november december i i
think it'll be
tease
and i think the tease for multiverse of
madness will be like showing events from
one division events from loki and some
events that we see in the trailer for
spider-man knowing home and just
basically it'll say like all these
events basically screwed everything up
and now there's a bigger threat coming
and kind of briefly talk about that not
maybe not tell us what the bigger threat
is but like
briefly talk about a bigger threat
so
hey alex mendoza welcome welcome welcome
well what if connect to the overall kang
arc
uh maybe i think at the end there's
gonna be a big multiversal like a what
if multiversal battle
but i think that's mostly ultron
so i'm not sure about kang
but i do think it is going to connect
to the mcu in some way shape or form and
what what i personally think is i think
it's going to be the the watcher that
connects i think
the watcher because they've said
that what if is a part of the mcu it's
in the same universe so if that's the
case then
the watcher is the watcher of
the entire multiverse so
that means he's the watcher of
loki the watcher
of uh hawkeye the watcher of the
avengers you know what i mean like
everyone is
or he's the watcher of everyone i mean
so uh kelsey foster there's a lot of
there's a lot of rumors going around for
multiverse of madness i've uh i've tried
to
there's a few that i've talked about
when they come from pretty credible
people but the problem is is like when
everybody just starts
throwing out rumors it's kind of just
like okay well
how are you credible
right so usually i'll only talk about
rumors or leaks or something if it's
come from people who have kind of proved
themselves
uh in the past and if not i very clearly
clearly state that this is a rumor and i
don't really know where it's coming from
do i think spiderman away home is the
best upcoming marvel movie the default
bacon
um
um
probably
but apparently
um
apparently doctor strange multiverse of
madness is supposed to be even bigger
so that's why i'm slightly hesitant to
say yes because
benedict cumberbatch recently said
he they said something like oh
spiderman home is going to be like the
most ambitious film
and then benedict cumberbatch said until
multiverse of madness so it's like oof
okay
do more dc videos i want to nothing ever
happens
um
and i missed the suicide squad
like buzz so i didn't want to jump in on
the end
and just be like where the heck are you
coming from
but for the batman heck yeah i'm gonna
start i'm gonna start talking about that
about start talking about other stuff as
well because i i really do like dc
and i think with the flash movie
i i think i think it's gonna get really
good i think they actually are
developing like their own universe now
so i'm gonna be excited to talk about dc
and like i just said well like i said in
the beginning of this i um
i just watched star wars visions the
very first episode i think it comes out
like next week but i got sent all the
episodes
and it's really cool um if for those
people who like anime you're really
really gonna like it
and
for this don't like anime you probably
won't like it
and guys
i i have perfectly fine audio my voice
is kind of going away
so maybe that's what you're hearing
uh thank you daniel marshall
um
so
if you can't hear me maybe check your
settings because
on my phone here
i have pretty good audio mr anderson
what do you think how we doing on audio
we doing okay
michael lapel yeah flashpoint i i can't
i can't wait i can't wait
uh i think it's gonna be really cool and
i think it's gonna really set up d it's
supposed to explain dc's like
multiversal universe or universe plans
you know so
i'm hearing some people say the episodes
out
not yet not on my part i only have to
episode five still what if zombies
uh
guys you're either trolling me about the
sound or maybe check your settings
because i got a lot of people
i'm still on the soft side uh
i mean i'll check my settings but i just
checked my phone and i'm very very loud
here i turned it up a little bit and
this i'm maxed out right now
i think it's just because i'm losing my
voice
well dr doctor strange two beat avengers
in game spidey boy um
probably not no
i think spider-man no way home might um
they just have to announce you know they
have to announce everything
oh that's a bummer speed draw pedro that
venom got delayed guys i heard a
i i heard some rumors
about
the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene
i won't say it in here because i know
not everybody likes spoilers
um
but if it's true
and this and some people did get to see
the movie um already
and there's been mixed reactions
which
is fine
but i think
if it's true
then everything's about to be a lot
bigger than we think it is i'll leave it
at that
hello everybody hello just a warning if
you guys spam
uh mr anderson will time you out and if
you do it enough he'll he might ban you
so just letting you guys know wow my
stream is actually really delayed
hello test
oh it's like 30 seconds delayed on on my
part
dang
sound is harsh as in i mean i don't even
know what that means but a lot of people
said this sounds good guys so maybe
check the sound on your end i have it on
my phone right here sounds fine to me i
also have it pulled up on another
monitor sounds good to me
uh i'm not going to say i'm not going to
be saying the venom post credit scene
right now because i'm not going to spoil
it for people but i will be doing a
video on it
i mean if you've like followed my
channel
you could probably guess what it is i've
been talking about it for a while
um
yeah yeah yeah
so i don't know if some of you
i don't know if some of you
heard me in the beginning i'm going to
do a breakdown of the episode kind of
right after
and i'm going to try like a different
style type of thing hey infinity shades
yeah great to see you too
doing all right yeah thanks so much yeah
i appreciate you always giving me
positive comments like that in the super
chats
uh they keep me going
wait is tyrone
magnus in the chat i see some people
saying his name
tyron's a cool dude
all right it's out
refresh
mr anderson will keep the time
what if killmonger rescued tony stark we
are starting in five
four
three
two
one
boom here we go
let's do
full screen
let's make sure i got all my stuff here
yep there we go
also if you like g fuel you can use my
code cosmic g fuel dot com you get like
a 10 to 30 discount depending on what
they're doing at the time
oh killmonger looks like tyrone magnus
that's funny
tyron's a cool dude he does reactions to
my stuff too
actually need some water
all right so we're just in the intro
right now as always
time
every time we start with this intro and
he says time and space i feel like it's
star trek and i'm about to hear space
the final frontier for some of you
younger guys you probably don't know
that but some of the older guys in there
you watch star trek you probably get it
i've never noticed this before are all
of the names that they're posting down
below in this current episode or
everywhere because it just said don
chanel and i just said paul bettany so
our vision and war machine gonna be in
this episode
huh
i am the watcher
executive producer kevin feige
ponder the question
what if
you get it mr anderson right oh snap
so that's tony stark obviously and we're
about to see the difference here
kanar province afghanistan
he's going to do the peace
yep yep yep
i'd be out of a job with peace
all right so here are the events from
oof the events from the first
yeah that's that's what you do you get
out of the military protected convoy
the missile
and
boom
it says
it says kill
killmonger
so it says killmonger
wait so
oh no that's the old stuff okay they're
showing us what would have happened
this is what would have happened
oh snap literally stop
iron man
so he would never become iron man
a valen was given a new chance
anywhere
young americans killed by the very
weapons
lieutenant eric stevens
he's the new chief security officer
he took happiest promotion
christine everhart
look who it is
so he
oh
oh snap
he uh oh he outed him
i brought receipts
no way
google it i dropped it online
oh no look at that oh yeah right get him
happy
yeah
bam blam blam
blam
and there's the star cows look at that
they died at the end
so he's taking c-o-o
so pepper doesn't become
ceo there's rudy
ready
hey liam's animation world
dang hoping get better
so the question is what does killmonger
want
huh
gang violence
automated combat drone
interesting
liberator
hey hey wow
i like anime
gundam i knew it
nano circuitry
interesting so they're going to build
this thing
that's pretty cool and then why
killmonger is going to take over the
world
they're a gundam
i'd like to know if this technology
exists somewhere like is there somebody
like i actually know somebody who owns
an a a webbing company
but i know he doesn't do this stuff
he he works with lockheed martin
okay oh that didn't work
it's only a failure if it explodes
oh power source
not all of it oh he's got vibranium
well okay
interesting
so they're gonna use that to power
claw
drop the purchase order
pepper does not like what's going on
salvage yard african coast here's claw
roadie
let's see the vibranium door melody
spear oh
ah
that's pretty funny uh 33 minute run
time
what you got rhody
that all vibranium
is that killmonger what is happening
here
killmonger's behind it all
yeah it's gotta be killmonger
yep
oh
is it actual black panther or is it
killmonger
oof
is it killmonger black panther
place your bets now
it looks like black panther
oh
it's black panther
killmonger's got a sound wave machine
what is happening here
jeez
wow
oh
what
oh
man
oh but they didn't wait
wait
did they just kill t'challa and roadie
they definitely killed rhodey but they
killed t'challa too that's kind of weird
that we
kind of had to watch that huh
whoa
is that freaking there's freaking ross
dang
okay
interesting tony sees it all
interesting interesting
oh snap
no
there's guitars in the background that's
funny
are you really shooting that thing
are you really trying to shoot that
thing you're really trying to shoot it
that's what happens
oh but the spears there
and it's vibranium
it's all that coming
gosh we freaking he just did he just
killed tony
didn't kill him yet
that wouldn't
kill him
look at the watcher just
watching
it's ross
is
tony has always
interesting
so
now killmonger has an army of gundams
okay
happy's going to save the day with his
bland bland blam look at that
so now they're going to go invade
wakanda because that's part of his plan
delivering them to shaw jeez
is he going to kill shaw
gonna kill shaw right now
a road trip
so he's enough
this
shaw dead
he's killing everybody and i really
don't like that
no
i let us believe that
look how young sherry is
i wish i could read all that i don't
know what it says
he's dead too right
he's gotta be dead
he's dead right i mean he's gotta be
dead
so
okay
shouldn't trust him
shouldn't trust him at all
she's the general whoo
for t'challa you bombay
bombay
this is not gonna end
well yeah let me guess like a billion
other lights are about to pop up
yep and there they are
yep
and america's attacking wakanda pretty
much
he's gonna kill them
open the shields
killmonger is mephisto confirmed
well it worked they stopped
are they dead
is he gonna kill him
of course he controls them now right
i'm trying to blame tony stark
so what's your plan killmonger
okay okay okay
oof
they still do have pretty big cannons on
those things
i don't like how he said wakanda forever
uh is he gonna go kill
the queen or koi i bet you he does
maybe not
oh look at that
i kind of really want him to die
like i really want him to die
they're all kicking butt though
iron man bots were better the iron
legion was better
is he gonna save a koi
he did he saved a koi
i'm kind of confused
how does he what's his plan because he's
having them attack
is he gonna kill her no
i mean he's basically just
it's just a
big stage act right i mean
oh that's cool she killed two and one oh
that was pretty cool
oh
for t'challa
so
which is a big stage act
but what's his plan now
okay
lion king scene here
so he's on the mount
nope
uh
he's gonna become the black panther
so he's gonna go to the astral plane now
and then he fights astral t'challa
right
and he gets his astral butt kicked
can the
yep that's t'challa
oh
i did what i had to do
oh
no
is
so what's pepper's plan
oh look who it is
sherry
together
is this
is that the end of the episode
that's kind of lame
that's he in the episode
i'm not liking these endings
we had to watch so many people die again
what is happening
i'm not like i'm not satisfied with the
last two endings i'm not satisfied with
the zombie ending and i'm not satisfied
with this ending at least this ending
makes it seem like we are going to get
another episode
uh
but i don't know
yeah i'm not sure i enjoyed it guys uh
um
i'm not
i'm not leaving this episode with a good
feeling i watched a lot of people die
and i hated killmonger and he
essentially won and then they left us
oh no
oh yeah that that wasn't that wasn't a
good one for me um
i can see how it's appealing to to some
people i don't ever judge like if you
think this episode's great that's that's
good that's awesome good for you i'm
glad you enjoyed it not my personal
favorite
let's get chris in here and let's talk
about this episode cause uh wow i was um
that was something uh
what yeah let's rate it guys put up put
put your ratings in the chat i'm seeing
some low ones uh ricky
246 like that it was an eight
uh
abraham ready was a seven
or six he just
there's eight there's a lot of cool
aspects to it i just i'm not leaving
with a incredible feeling
oh are you sure
oh are you sure about that chris
are they sure
dude that's so
um
i didn't like this one
so that's the first thing i said was i'm
leaving
i didn't like the ending because it's a
cliffhanger at least this one
right i don't think the zombie one does
because
the watcher was like and that ends the
universe right oh yeah
you know the uh overall
big
final that we think we're seeing yeah
why can't i how do i change there we go
is it impossible that you could share
your screen that disney plus is going to
be on
on discord
i don't know how i can actually show it
on your stream or on discord on my
stream
oh okay i didn't know if you were
playing because i have you yeah this
might
this might not work
this straight up might not work um well
what's the issue how do i put the screen
on
because you're on
well can you not just pull it up on that
one and then screen share it on discord
and then it'll show on both
me and if pull it up on what one
on the one that your discord's on so
pull it up on the computer your
discord's on and then screen share it
and then it will show your
your discord and it'll show me and that
as well we'll try uh jordan lane thanks
for the super chat uh it has been
confirmed there will be a season two of
what if yes
all right so hold on what am i doing
here i'm screen sharing
share your screen
and then you can share like me and half
of it
or it and
half of me or something like that on
your
discord like you would if you were
sharing my picture i'm i'm sharing right
now
maybe not
watch stream
am i
i'm looking it says i am
and then if you switch your the camera
you're currently using
um
then you could put you here and we can
both be here looking at it nope i can't
attach a camera to this
but that's how we do it next time
that is how we would have to yeah what
if you grabbed alex's real quick i don't
even see my my stream
yeah it's not popping up yeah
the stream you're viewing currently has
reduced video or audio quality this was
a failed experiment well we could put it
on mine i would need your password real
quick because i don't know
you don't have disney plus oh they have
it i don't know
all right guys we're gonna try to you
know we're gonna try to get this going
so we can uh do a breakdown
but uh extra information to me whichever
yeah if you think i know that crap off
the top of my head
so okay but so here's here's my
here's my
i didn't i'm not leaving this episode
feeling good
i watched a lot of people die that i
didn't want to die i hated killmonger
the whole entire time and he essentially
won and people like him a lot he's the
new black panther i'm not feeling good
and then it didn't really end right it
left us no there's no resolution
yeah
so i'm not saying it was bad it just
made me feel bad
yeah
that was that was a rough one to watch
and be like oh i am enjoying myself
right now yeah
uh dj wavyd thanks super chat least
favorite since episode one i don't know
if that means you liked one more or you
like this one more but either way i feel
you
yeah not my personal favorite um
i'm happy for the people that did enjoy
it because it's nice to enjoy things
but uh
yeah i'll tell you what though i did
watch the first episode of star wars
visions i liked it
if you like anime you like it if you
don't you won't like it
yeah there's a lot that i liked about
the episode
but like
i just
i'm not like the point of the story is
to make you hate him and they did that
but i don't care to hate him i just want
to see the people i like do well yeah
so wait hold on i'm confused
no that's not it okay it's this so how
do i share this screen
streaming channel smoother video
streaming quality better
whatever let's try this
maybe we can get it going
i mean you could also add another scene
maybe
i don't know if that it's actually
possible i don't know you need a third
monitor
you need more screens uh i have enough
um
are you doing it now let's see if it
worked
yeah
trying
it's trying nope it's not working again
i could pull it up on mine for some
reason i have actually nitro somebody
give to me nitrous i'll be able to pull
up in 10 1080.
so can you get in
uh if you sent me yeah let me look that
ain't gonna work i bet you won't work
we'll try
yeah thank you for becoming a community
member i'm not ignoring you i'm going to
look at it in just a second we're trying
to fix something we actually should have
uh
done this definitely should have done it
before
um
it did show why
it did show why killmonger can't return
as a good character because
he's not good i think it's like it's one
of those things where it's like
what is it in your heart are you a good
person or are you a bad person because
it's kind of like
i don't know i get vengeance
like that's a story arc i can understand
but one thing
i mean i guess tony's arrogance um
tony's arrogance
could lead him to trust somebody like
that but no way he like makes him c-o-o
and all that stuff like like there's
just like i just don't see that i i also
don't know
here's something that is here is
something that has bugged me
that's not the email
try to warn another cosmic wonder
something that bubs bugs me
is in the first
episode
they said
bam that's the point
that's where the universe changed they
have not done that since the first
episode
they haven't like told us like this is
like where was the moment
in which killmonger decided to go save
tony stark
they didn't show that they just kind of
said
that he just showed up and then they
were like he's like oh yeah i
intercepted this okay
well why like what was the difference
there why did that change that's
something that i'm like
then i'm kind of like okay
i don't get it
yeah extra to talk to the child apart at
the end was really really really cool
hey i did it it's the yahoo account
yahoo
born at yahoo
really
really really oh
yeah marvel just continued uh
conditioned us to watch t'challa jai die
isaiah richardson jr thanks to super
chat i know i i actually was like when
they did that i was like wait
did they just make us watch t'challa die
like granted it's animated
um
but still
no stop talking stop talking okay
not you the watcher okay
be silent the watcher so now okay you
have to now you turn off your stream
thingy yeah and let me
share my screen which should be
this screen
go live
now figure out how to get that on the
screen
okay
but how do i like
grid maybe
i will figure this out or
maybe in the future then that's how
that's 100 i would do in the future but
for now
you just have to finagle it a better
idea
oh wait
no i got it i got it right here i'm just
gonna did you i'm just gonna overlay
that box with me
there you go
yeah good enough
okay
let's go over this
let's do
it does it show up or is it black oh no
dang it oh it's not playing
yeah are you playing it and it's not
going through
yeah it's not going through oh those
clever sons of guns
they're trying to make everything
impossible those clever boys guys we're
trying to do a live breakdown we were
trying to do a live breakdown the world
doesn't want it apparently yeah see so
there it is now yeah
and then yeah it just doesn't play
just goes black on the stream labs yeah
well that's yeah because i can i can see
all the pictures when you scroll
oh can you yeah
frame by frame boys frame by frame boom
boom boom
i don't know for for those people like
the i think the doctor strange episode
was really good that's an episode i
didn't dislike that that's probably my
third favorite
third
yeah
zombie's the second and the second one's
still my first
well you know what i'm just gonna pull
you up and then i'll go
i can pull mine up actually i might i
might have figured i might i might have
an idea
oh someone said play it on google chrome
i'm on google chrome oh
google chrome it's either discord or
which is weird because i definitely
thought discord let you share that stuff
but it could just be disney plus
might just be impossible
yeah
lamos
weird weird weird
but
i think i i think i might have a way
to do it
you know what i must
certainly have a way to do it let me
just kind of
go
bay leaf thank you for um becoming a
community member and marina thank you
for the super chat again always
supporting the channel how are you doing
i think i have it
guys
well that's the important one so we can
figure out maybe another way later but
as long as you have it then
yeah i think i
i think i i think i can i think i
actually can't figure out how to do this
i think i got it right here
i just lost chris
no i'm here i just turned off my okay
all right
does this work i can't see my stream to
like know if this works
you got to pull it up on your phone
oh it does it does wait wait is it kind
of working
let me see yeah no that works okay sweet
i don't know how you're doing that but
it's working oh wait but it's like so
big
you gotta make it smaller i gotta make
one just make the uh
oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
whole window yeah and just put it under
us yeah
what is that on is it you're just
playing it well it's just my right it's
my right pc
oh so i'll just do that and we'll just
kind of do it apart
what well no you
i can't see it on we're just going to go
frame by frame that's what i'm talking
about from my
to see it oh word word word
okay
and i'll just get next week we'll get a
video of you on here because i won't be
able to get you on here because there's
no way for me to do that but that's okay
we'll do that next week
next week we'll definitely have it
better okay but this week here we go
guys we're doing a live breakdown how do
i got to mute this okay so
yeah make sure it's needed
yeah definitely muted but okay so
here here's here's something that it
it's curious to me because and let me
pull up the chat here on my phone so i
don't miss anything
there we go there we go
everyone this is chris uh i'm chris
i can't see myself
because it's covering it so i got a
point
we both need this way
this is chris cosmic culture he's also
like a room away from me we live in the
same place
um be sure to subscribe to him if you
haven't yet we're gonna do a live
breakdown here we're just gonna see this
see see how it works we're gonna see how
it works
um
so let's go ahead and start at the
beginning
if you haven't seen it this is kind of
your chance to like see it see it a
little bit we're not going to play
through a lot of it because we're going
to get copyrighted but in the beginning
it opens up the same as
it does in the very first ironman movie
this is the start of the mcu here
there's even the part
we'll take it back a little bit there's
even the part where they talk about and
they do the peace sign as we can see
right here and the events play out the
same the events play out the same until
we get and to this moment right here
missile comes down he sees stark
industry
and instead of
from here on out this is the point where
it changes from what happens to iron man
to what happens in this new universe
right because then killmonger comes
grabs it and checks it
and it even says killmonger on his vest
and why is that because he's he's a navy
seal right now right
so this kind of shows us
not shows us but tells us a little bit
of the past that killmonger had before
and i mean
i think most of us have seen the episode
you're probably watching this if you've
seen the episode
we know that his intentions aren't so
good but basically from here killmonger
saves them and they kind of go off right
now
this is where the watchers start to show
us that all these events that would
eventually go on to happen
all the way up until this point right
here
tony stark aka iron man snapping to save
you know the entire universe they don't
happen
and this actually makes you wonder
since killmonger has killed a lot of
like the heroes
tony stark
black panther
don shadow
well rhodey
um
the earth is missing a lot
the earth is missing a lot of their
protectors and thanos is still coming
right
thanos is still out there trying to
kill half the population physically
while also trying to obtain the stone so
we can do in a snap
so
killmonger is really really altered
the events of what happens in the mcu
specifically
infinity ward end game
anything to add chris
i mean i think it's really cool that we
get the sequence from the watcher and he
keeps referencing and we definitely need
to point this out the main mcu timeline
yeah right and i realized that in this
episode when we saw this scene that you
have pulled up there
um
like he keeps referencing back to the
main mcu timeline
and i guess it really was the sacred
timeline so maybe these all of these in
the what f episode are branching off
from the time of loki so there are there
is that main connection there as well
which i always think is
just kind of interesting to make out i
think the most asked question to you and
me
from all of you guys is
are these guys going to connect to the
main mcu timeline and i still don't know
the answer to that just yet but if
anything the main
sacred timeline is there
and um the watcher is aware of that and
i think the watcher is actually the
connection to the main timeline because
if this watcher
is the watcher over all of the
multiverse and the producers have said
that this does connect to the mcu
well
okay that means the watcher is the
watcher of
our secret time bring all that knowledge
over right right well this happened here
and if you do it this way it happened
this way so that's actually really true
so out of everything we've seen
and you know it's just kind of
background information and something
that has been on our face but not
addressed
you know if the watcher makes his way
over to the mcu and he's aware of the
main mcu timeline which obviously he is
if he's referencing iron man snap here
if we get him in the in the real live
action side he can reference any of this
anything like yeah well when it when you
did it this way this is what happened
it's like hey we watched that what if
now also you have to keep in mind for
what if in the main
mcu multiverse of madness makes anything
possible right but
at the watcher in the comics even though
he's like sworn not to be able to
interfere
he does
he still does he still does eventually
and i think that'll happen in the mcu
right and at one point time in the
comics like the council of all the
watchers they kick him out
now eventually he gets back in because
he still watches over earth when they
kick him out right
um but he loves the fantastic four he
helps fantastic four
and i think perhaps in multiverse of
madness
we're gonna see the watcher maybe
interfere and maybe that's how the
rumored live-action captain carter comes
in right
because i think she comes from one of
these universes that we're seeing and
what if
i think
because it's clear we've seen by now
marvel actually released it today the
the halfway point trailer or whatever
they call it
and we saw some more team-ups
and i think this is leading to a bunch
of multiverses colliding into each other
um and eventually will lead into the the
live-action mcu
and i think like you just said the
watcher is the big link there so that's
important to notice for sure oh for sure
i i think it's all the watcher all right
so getting back here subtitles since i
don't have any uh
um camping in the audio so a villain was
given a new chance this part's kind of
interesting because i mean they they
lead you to believe that you know
killmonger can actually be good and we
do believe it for a while now this
part's kind of sad
because
we figure out kind of what we figured
out at the end of the first iron man
right we know who the real bad guy is
and
tony stark has promoted c-o-o in his
place now we're skipping all of that
obviously because we're not going
through any of the events of the first
iron man because tony stark doesn't
actually ever become iron man
so if we skip here
we know who she is
she was in the iron
you know she uh she's on the iron man's
we see her
repeatedly
and yep there it is
abba
yeah it's kind of cool how this kind of
gives you
i mean it
it doesn't tell us anything that we
didn't really know from the first iron
man
but again what i think i'm missing from
this episode
is it doesn't it doesn't tell us where
like the universe changed
you know what i mean like it doesn't
tell us like and this is the reason
in this universe killmonger decided to
go save tony or he stumbled upon that
information because that's the
difference
in the universe killmonger finding that
information and saving tony now he out
of adayah
and he becomes a ceo
he gets arrested happy doesn't get
promoted not like he was supposed to his
head of security it's unfortunate
because i love happy and i honestly
thought he was going to save the day of
going blam blam blam
blam punches the guy blamed good
yeah but
so as we go through party at tony's
house party at the
party party at the mansion you know
getting major you know iron man iron man
2 vibes here
yep um
roadie's there you know
peppers talk to him
so this is this is kind of funny because
tony's promoting him
right to the to the co
but killmonger is going i'm just a
soldier right
i'm just a soldier and this is a perfect
like play here right it's it's it's a
very sneaky
koi here as he's as this is exactly what
he wants right
he wants to get in close with tony he
wants to get really tight with stark
industries
and he's doing that by kind of
playing it off like well you know i'm
just a soldier i'm not that smart of a
guy you know what i mean blah blah blah
blah and tony eats it up now he saved
tony's life
but tony eats it up
now this is a part where i don't think
i think the arrogance of tony stark gets
in the way a little bit too much oh for
sure because perfect way of putting it
right just the arrogance of tony stark
just to trust this guy just because he
saved his life
and just because you know he's navy seal
which i mean i would like to think you
could trust in abco we're obviously
talking about fictional universe
um but i think against navy seals please
don't come find it i have friends that
are navy seals they're freaking awesome
yeah so but this part right here i mean
and he's drinking right mind you but
he's pretty much drinking the whole
entire time in this episode up until his
death you know like if we think about
that but so that's when he says i want
you by my side i want a killer
figuratively but you know a literal one
wouldn't matter it wouldn't be bad
either because you know
it's nice especially for tony stark now
pepper meets with um
roadie right
and rhodey's like his slate's clean
right can't find anything on him and
pepper says like yeah and that's why i
don't trust him
this is
this is kind of where we kind of start
to go okay
what's going on does he actually want
something
or
you know is pepper just being paranoid
but as we go on
tony kind of shows them all of his toys
they bond over their fathers yeah that's
cool now killmonger eric knows
everything he knows everything about
tony stark this is his plan for a long
time like this is his vengeance right so
instead of the events of black panther
happening
it's completely different his plan to
get back into wakanda and take over
wakanda is to actually go through tony
stark he's a major part of his plan why
because he has to build what they call
their gundams right and he actually says
i like anime so it literally is
kind of designed after gundam wing which
is kind of cool for the animation like
anime right for the anime
easter egg there
so killmonger again you know uses
what he knows will work with tony they
both lost their fathers right
um their parents are both orphans in a
way right so he uses that and he tells
tony you know i had this idea
and it was basically to
build a gundam is what he said there was
an idea there was an idea that iron man
would become the death of himself by
trusting a random person that he met
that's safe
that's not how it goes
so
they design it right and it's funny
because at one point in time they're
searching for a power supply and he says
right here hey
if we could minior miniaturize
our arc reactor
and he's like no that wouldn't work no
that wouldn't work
i'm just drunk
which is obviously what ends up
happening in iron man and it's obviously
his arc reactor which he would never go
on to get in this universe because he
would never go on to become iron man he
would never have the shrapnel constantly
trying to kill his heart which is what
he did the art reactor for well so
that's just like a little pun there but
then the idea comes to use vibranium
and eric still has some left and
that's what they decide they need they
need some vibranium so who
now comes into the picture claw
claw because he has the vibranium and
where did we learn this from
age of ultron which and we were in the
same building
what do you mean
that building the little locker where
they had all the vibranium yeah same
build yeah it's the same from age of
ultron yep yeah same with atrial film
um now
problem is
they need kind of a diplomatic way to do
everything and pepper kind of realizes
that
this is kind of killmonger's plan
because she's like oh you probably don't
agree and then he's like no i i do agree
and then he says but unless we can
secure some kind of diplomatic cover
now again
all part of the plan because he wants to
kill roadie
right he wants war machine out well i
guess he's not never becomes war machine
right right no that doesn't happen right
again
huge alterations in this universe uh
ventures probably
either don't get formed or form in a
very very different way because i guess
yeah i guess fury's still there and caps
you know under the ice maybe or no not
at this point he's not on the ice but
so he says we're gonna use some
diplomatic cover and that's where roadie
comes in so we go to claw
and he kind of teases him shows him some
vibranium
and uh
shows some spear of the door milaje
but rhodey's like yeah you know tony
stark's twitch as hell and he's kind of
negligent with his money he kind of uses
that all like in an afternoon 10 million
dollars no big deal so we see all the
vibranium that he had
we see the vibranium that he had from
age of ultron and this
this is kind of the same until it takes
a weird turn that i wasn't expecting
yeah yeah you want to walk us through
this one
well we find out killmonger is actually
a bad guy which i think a lot of people
are either guessing or weren't guessing
i didn't see them going in this
direction i was actually hoping to see
tony stark and pepper make their way
into wakanda and actually even maybe see
iron man go ahead and make the vibranium
suit right out of the get-go you know my
thought was well he's still iron man
talked about that before
yeah right it's like that'll be really
cool to see yeah and we did talk about
that before the episode today i was like
i can't wait to see that that'll be
really cool to see
uh oh my name's blinking her name's
linking on me right now
t'challa's sister shuri
shuri thank you shuri and iron man like
get to be together that's where we
thought it was going right right
obviously it didn't killmonger reveals
himself to be a bad guy
and i think claw actually puts it in the
perfect way when he says i'd hate to
play chess against you right because you
really do get an appreciation for
killmonger's intelligence yeah which is
very very very high and we don't really
get to see that in black panther
um not to this level like the game of
chess he's playing right and everybody
else is playing candyland like let me
tell you this is incredible so he shows
up and he just starts dropping fools
he's able to make it look like black
condoms
right
black panther was killed by the
americans black panther makes his line
it was kind of
disappointed to see black panther
getting taken down that easily because
that was something isn't gonna happen
especially without him having the purple
heart seemed very unreal realistic to me
well he did have like stark technology
which
sound is different i think sound is
different you know
yeah
because like i don't know if you've ever
had like like i've had guns fired like
really close to my ears not wearing ear
protection because
stupid
and it can really
really hurt
like
like inside your body like it can hurt
so
i guess if he wasn't expecting it and
you know it's good powerful start tech i
felt like it was a little cheap to make
the story work but again you make a good
point there well that's the only way
probably eric thought that he could
because he he's familiar enough with
vibranium to know that he just can't
like puncture t'challa right like rhodey
was shooting him and t'challa just
walked up to him and it's just bam
literally
like literally a suit made of captain
america's shield it's a suit that's a
shield so how do you beat that i guess
that's one of the only ways you could
and i guess that's another reflection on
killmonger's intelligence not just
politically exactly you know in combat
which shows up later in the episode and
it's cool to see but yeah so we get back
to to iron man and he's placing all
these different things and all of his
games working out perfectly or to tony
stark i suppose
and uh it really was set up really cool
and and you know you don't want to root
for the guy who's killing all these
beloved characters but yeah i do have to
credit him like his intelligence
it is pretty cool to see him play this
this really cool game of chess against
everybody else for his own agenda yeah
it was really sad that we
had to see t'challa die right um
just because of everything obviously in
real life yeah that was rough i actually
thought to myself i'm surprised they did
i'm surprised i'm surprised they did
that i'm surprised i didn't change it at
all
right but hey you know it's what if
different world it's what if and
eventually killmonger gets back to tony
uh
and you can never ever ever
underestimate the intelligence of tony
stark despite how
arrogant he is
because he doesn't go through all those
experiences that kind of change him
right
in this one
so
despite however arrogant he is he's
still a genius and you can't you can't
really put that past them so killmonger
comes in i brought you this souvenir and
uh
you know
tony's basically you know
jarvis saw everything you can't get
anything past jarvis
and
he puts everything on lockdown
right all the like military-grade
bunkers come down
and killmonger's like what the heck you
think you're going to beat me
he's like nah but the vibranium worked
as a power source so i made
a gundam
right so essentially
almost the first iron man comes in
and fights killmonger now the problem is
the reason why it was so easy for
killmonger to defeat
the let's call
gundam is because tony stark says it you
know it's programmed after him
you know he says it right here
you forgot you programmed the drone
yourself your moves are his moves i
guess i got a freestyle that's kind of
where tony went wrong
why didn't you tell him that right
well there's tony's arrogance right
isn't curved by being iron man and
nearly dying and you really see
and that's cool because we see a tony
stark that we don't see in the mcu
because right from the ground iron man
right from the ghost iron man and that
arrogance is um served a little it's
curved a little like how you say that
but it's also put in check
right so that's the thing like
throughout the mcu he's he has
constantly has to come in contact with
well i wasn't exactly right
exactly and that doesn't happen here
this is tony thinking he's right about
everything
and eventually just goes on to
killmonger defeats it and unfortunately
we have to watch uh
we have to watch our tony die
which again
was not expected and i'm kind of
confused here because it's like did you
just
i feel like that wouldn't kill you
and you it it's probably about two
minutes inside of you you wouldn't lose
that much blood especially since it is
inside of you still
but maybe keeping it less graphic and
it's like to his heart but not really
yeah
but it wasn't
not even close
opposite side yeah but eventually you
know pepper realizes what's the deal
it's killmonger but unfortunately
you know ross is there and like is ross
ever play
a beneficial role towards the good guys
ever
luckily jerk right he just he's ross
he is never right i've never seen like
black widow all this stuff you know so
he takes over stark industries you know
paycheck that and all of a sudden
killmonger because ross trusts him
because of the military background right
his navy seal
all of a sudden ross gets the army that
was his plan the entire time that was
just planned the entire time and ross
gets that er and killmonger gets that
army
and
this is where his plan actually gets
really intricate
and this is where i kind of appreciate
it because again it's like
dang
this guy planned all this and it
actually worked and so you have
he goes back to claw
this is technically you know the
military's army at this point in time
right now and ross even says you just
created you know the most advanced
military
whatever system against you know of the
21st century
so
this part is kind of crazy where
killmonger and claw they actually go
to the borders of wakanda
now eric is from wakanda right
and he knows a little bit what his dad
told him but when they get to like the
barricade the the barrier
he doesn't see anything and he's like i
don't get it and call actually knows
like there's a kind of a force field
that also
mass and makes the city invisible
killmonger doesn't actually know that so
there is some things that he doesn't
know which i found very interesting
so this is where he discovers it but
that's pretty much what he needed claw
for so you know after that
[Music]
kind of did some dying he killed claw
and i and this is like i actually didn't
like this part
really yeah because i was like okay
you're bad and you've killed a bunch of
good guys and he's like i'm just gonna
kill another bad guy too that i
legitimately helped him and i'm just
kind of like oh my gosh like
all right
i get it you're a douche
well he cheated him he needed him so
that's the next thing i was gonna say he
needed him to convince the door milaje
and to convince the people of wakanda
you know
that he's on their side and then he even
goes on to show him you know the marking
on his lips they tell him who he tells
them who he is
uh
prince of jabbu and
shows them the thing shows them the
marking so of course they have to
adhere it's kind of like you know this
kind of like in the first black panther
they have to adhere to that right you
know they have to
because it's like the royalty things
like a big deal so
so it goes in and of course everybody's
still
you know what the heck this is
impossible
we know the story from black panther
where the father is the one
who actually killed him right
um
so the big thing with his father his
uncle killmonger's uncle
but it kind of goes a little bit
different
excuse me
he
i think shuri's the only voice of reason
here
because i think the guilt
of
tichaka
is too much
um because of the death of his brother
and now his nephew killmonger is back
but that leads to
what we
actually haven't seen but i can guess
we're going to see the ultimate
destruction of
what maybe not the destruction of
wakanda but the destruction of
tachaka and t'challa's family
in charge of wakanda
because i definitely because you know he
becomes black panther at the end like
and now he's all powerful
and now he has access to a bunch of
vibranium and
i'm assuming in wakanda he could build
these armies again
oh for sure if he has all this he's now
black panther he has all their trust
you know if we were to get a part two we
would still see you know the breakout of
now general ross being general ross
versus
a fully armed and ready to go
hillmonger and honestly wakanda's
probably winning that fight nine times
out of ten oh for sure
for sure
but you know we had a pretty cool battle
we had a pretty gold battle and angela
you know
i'm glad she she
came back and voiced this because
her character is really awesome actually
is that her
i didn't really look let's take a look
at that real fast
i think it look if it wasn't they they
like really nailed
some of these characters let's take a
look
let me get
angela yeah
it was her so it was really cool seeing
queen ramonda as
general raimondo right
right that that's that's really cool man
we saw a koi 2
and
this this whole scene here where they
were fighting the robots i actually
really enjoyed
um i thought it was really really cool
and again killmonger is smart he planned
this entire thing to where if they shut
the barrier
the basically what's happening is the
transmission from the drones to
ross two stark industries will be lost
because of how powerful the barrier is
but killmonger had a remote switch
it was able to reactivate them but the
communication back to the home base
is still cut off they just kind of came
back online right because ross didn't
see anything right ross didn't see
killmonger
fighting
the gundams
right so as far as ross is concerned
killmonger is still a good guy he just
didn't win the battle because remember
he couldn't see
now shuri questioned him the entire time
yeah and at the end she kind of pops up
there before we get to that
killmonger jumps on the rhino which was
legitimately cool and this whole scene
right here this whole scene right here
again going back to killmonger's just
intelligence this is him
showing the people i'm with you i'm
fighting with you
you know not that they kind of had a
reason to think that the the army of
gundams was his but if they did that's
gone now because he helped destroy them
all
now we got some really cool scenes here
like really of okoye queen ramonda and
killmonger all fighting together like it
was pretty cool it was really really
cool to see
and i i'm hoping black panther 2 is like
this
in some way shape or form and i wonder
if they could bring killmonger back in
black panther 2 in some
way that's not steaming form yeah in
some way that's not stupid
you know what i mean like oh we need a
black panther here's killmonger right
he's like oh yep come back turns out he
wasn't actually dead like maybe
oh yeah they kind of gave him a
heart-shaped herb
and it kind of kept him alive and he was
life or death for like a really long
time but you know after like
a month he finally came out of a coma
and came back i don't know something
like that maybe
something like that now
he he eventually hits
he he kills the last
gundam
and he stabs it through the stark
industry logo
and that kind of is another just nod
towards
i hated you tony stark you were just my
means to an end and jabbing it through
the logo is the end right and there it
is right that's done that's the end now
we're in stark's dead
everything i needed for the means to the
end has now ended i'm done
and what happens after
that well he gets on the mountain and
talks to his uncle
and now he takes the heart-shaped herb
and becomes black panther and that is
the end of his plan right but
it seems like the way this ending is
here
where he goes and we see
t'challa again and we hear chadwick
again which was really really cool
because you know we only thought we were
going to see him in one episode and he's
been in what three now
this is the third time before i thought
he was only going to be in the in the
second episode and we've seen him right
three and i think there's another one no
i think he does show up he shows up
again yeah at the end
because because he's part of the
trailer where pepper is in wakanda right
we have
so is that the part two then we have
party thor then we have the last one
because we've seen pepper with um
yeah we have so there's three so they
are gonna readdress this
they are going to address this in this
season
right they have to because of the
trailers that we've seen i mean i guess
there could be some other thing that
brings pepper pepper to wakanda but i
feel like that'd be a repetitious
different storyline so perhaps we
actually do get a part two what if which
i suppose means t'challa probably won't
be in it unless he comes back as another
one of these panther ghosts well check
this out check this out i just had a
thought
what if
what if killmonger
decides to take jarvis and creates
ultron
and that could be a possibility because
remember the final the what we've seen
is a bunch of people fighting ultron
like droids
but we you're right we have seen pepper
and wakanda so we have
yeah so what it what if killmonger
thinks he can do a better jarvis and he
makes the makes it out of vibranium and
essentially creates ultron
and there's the
multiversal thread ultron with the
infinity stones can destroy the entire
throne in the middle of that somehow i
don't know if party thor comes into play
but i think that might be
i think humongous might create ultron
because we know ultron's going to come
right and he's going to have the means
to do it it's set up right now that it
would make sense yeah and maybe the
party thor episode is a way to get other
characters involved
as well yeah totally as you know we saw
in the mid credit trailer today
party thor and doctor strange but it
looked like you know the um
crazy powerful one
whose name is blinking supreme strange
supreme supreme yeah
i do think right yeah
so maybe that's gonna bring those two
into it and then it all meets up at the
end so there's a part two next week
maybe i'm making all this up part two
next week maybe party thor which
introduces other characters yeah yeah
yeah better word i am theorizing because
i do that for for a living um subscribe
um
and then we get the final episode which
will be everybody trying to take down
killmonger
and ultra and ultron
maybe i actually think ultra might kill
killmonger which would be lit
it would be lit i would very much be for
that but that would be a cool way of
kind of i think it was
finalizing not a real word but why not
be arising on words now too aren't you
yeah i'll do whatever i need to all
words
um would that be a
you know some what if episodes at the
end because you know zombies isn't
coming back right right right the first
the second one's not going to i do think
as coming back yeah i think we get as in
like these final three episodes here
assuming we only get nine and not ten
how do you think they connect a little
bit more towards the end so that'd be
cool to see pepper and shuri together
doing something in wakanda trying to
figure out how to be killmonger
killmonger off making ultron right party
for hanging out with who knows who else
bringing them into the fold and then bam
episode nine well this definitely isn't
done right because it seemed like yeah
and you know what i would actually
really love to see when t'challa when
they're in the astral plane at t'challa
is like you know either in in your plane
in the real world or in this plane like
you're gonna have to face something at
some point in some time
so i'm hoping ultron actually kills him
and then like and we're very good we see
this plane and t'challa does like kicks
his butt as a spirit or something like
that and all the other previous kings
and stuff like that too right like i i
hope we see that i hope we see that yeah
and i hope they don't give killmonger
like a redemption in that next i think
he's gone too far now he's killed how
many people yeah but at the end they
definitely set up the next one
you know pepper
sure no shuri tells pepper everything
pepper never trusted killmonger sherry
never tries to kill monger now they're
gonna bond we know pepper is gonna go to
wakanda because we've seen that that
that shot in the trailer that we got
today and i think we've seen it before
too
um
and they left us on that cliffhanger but
it but now that we realize that
it does it's nice to know that they
probably aren't going to
they probably aren't going to leave us
on that cliffhanger for long
i certainly hope that's the case yeah
yeah so what what was this episode
called what if killmonger rescued tony
stark
well the next episode could be what if
yeah right what if
sure he kicked killmonger's butt
you know uh something like that so
i do think the next one
if not
the next one one of the future episodes
that we're about to get these last three
are going to be a continuation of this
but
what do you guys think let us know what
you think in the comments do you think
you know it's very clear that we get
this
this season
but what do you think the ultimate
ending is leading up to it does seem
like it's all kind of leading up to
stuff now
so what do y'all think it is
be sure to let us know below also if you
haven't subscribed to chris over at
cosmic culture be sure to do so uh mr
anderson if you could drop that link in
the chat because i know you'd probably
be chris
because you beat him
every
every time now already doing it
yeah um
definitely turka turn i wasn't expecting
yeah that that was not what i thought
the episode was gonna be at all
um
i actually thought killmonger was gonna
be a good guy and i actually thought
i thought it was gonna fight alongside
t'challa
which i think would
be really cool i don't know if it's like
legal in wakanda to like
because t'challa would have obviously
had the heart-shaped herb in power
but if he was in his his black panther
suit and killmonger got his own suit as
well
i thought that would have been pretty
cool to see like fighting together
instead of fighting
you know separately
i was hoping that we were actually going
to see a redeemed killmonger here
because i think the character is insane
uh like i said and we were talking about
his intelligence and him playing this
chess game on this just crazy global
political
war level it wouldn't cool to see that
working with black panther like you were
just saying it would have been fantastic
to see and then you have iron man with
all this vibranium doing his good stuff
but now they went a different direction
with it and i wasn't prepared for
mentally
well and and you know you kind of got a
map i guess they have to map out like
i don't know how killmonger is supposed
to be 25 to 30 in this or maybe 25-35 i
don't know so you have to imagine that
he's gone 20 years or so with vengeance
in his mind so i guess
i guess that doesn't change right and
that's what you have to think of as like
a writer like does this change who he is
blah blah blah like no it doesn't really
change like he still had those events
happen when he was a kid
lost his dad no mom you know like he's
still gonna be that
vengeful person and so he just went
about it a different way which clearly
worked better for him
t'challa's gone he's the black panther
you know and everybody is on the side i
guess we'll see because uh pepper and
sure are on to him
and
they're gonna see yeah so
that was our live breakdown guys we're
trying something new um thought it would
be cool to do it with you guys here
uh isaiah richardson thanks to super
chat i say the last episode will be all
the universes colliding into a
multiversal war
with the watcher intervening we've seen
clips captain card and others all
running together i agree
and thanks for the super chat i agree um
i think he is going to interfere
and i hope that might lead to him in the
regular right that's what i hope it
leads to the regular him appearing in
the uh in the regular mcu
i think that would be really really
really cool
so but all right guys that's it for us
tonight it's very late
and we still gotta do some work uh yeah
on the we're gonna post this breakdown
tomorrow
add a little bit to it and uh
i think i also have a cool video i'm
losing my voice right now
if i can regain my voice uh we should
have a cool another cool video coming
out tomorrow as well so
thanks everybody for stopping by thank
you to mr anders anderson for being a
great mod thank you to everybody who
super chatted thank you to everybody who
normal chatted and thanks to everybody
who just came and watched and and if
you're just sitting back and enjoying
yourself appreciate everybody uh
subscribe to chris at cosmic culture if
you haven't yet
and as always
go ahead say something chris
say bye i was gonna say yeah
uh subscribe now seriously this was fun
we love doing stuff live with you guys
and being able to chat and um make sure
you subscribe to warren if you haven't
already
and oh yeah what imma hit you with one
wolf
oh no
oh no so i do the other wolf
yeah
and then the chat will do one more
the chat will give us one more
um no you guys are awesome
we're gonna get to work
and we will see you guys a week from
tonight
for episode seven who knows what that's
gonna be but
hopefully it's a good one so
love you all see you next time woof